kim zolciak Biermann reveals new details  about her medical emergency kim sat down  with good morning america to talk about  suffering a mini-stroke a TI a that  stroke landed kim in the hospital and  forced her to miss dancing with the  stars which lost Kim her slot in the  competition but actually was a blessing  in disguise the minor CIA revealed that  I have a PF 0 which is something which  is like a hole in your heart that I was  born with that never closed and so at  that point and do the doctors think that  may have led to the stroke that's what  caused it basically correct because the  blood clot was able to crossover through  the hole whereas most people don't have  that and it doesn't it's not able to do  that Kim said she was disappointed that  she was disqualified from the show but  she will be back to perform on the  finale